I'm Caroline Moore and I'm a junior at Warwick Valley High School in Warwick, New York.
Since I was a little girl, I've always been curious about the world around me...
...and I think that definitely plays a big part in my interest in astronomy.
It's a hobby I share with my Dad.
When she got more and more involved, I decided to build an observatory,...
...where we could have all the equipment permanently mounted and start observing.
So, I'm what they call a supernova hunter.
I take pictures of the night sky and I scan them looking for noticeable changes.
One night, I was looking at some images...
...and I came across something that looked kind of interesting.
So, that's when I Googled the galaxy to see what I could find.
After searching for a while,...
...I realized that I might have discovered my first supernova.
So, I sent it into the International Astronomical Union.
And it was late one evening, and a friend of ours called up...
...and said he needed to speak to Caroline...
...and then he broke the news to her that she had discovered...
...and become the youngest person ever to discover a supernova.
And I would just start jumping up and down, screaming and everything.
It was great.
I would just come in to school and kids would chant, "Supernova, supernova!"
So yeah, I'm very proud.
But again, a little jealousy.
There's competition between us.
He's out in the observatory every night, too...
...so I definitely need to find another one.